[Música]
i
conocí a nicolás en el segundo año de la
carrera
y nos hicimos muy amigos empezamos a
compartir una visión conjunta esto nos
llevó a hacer muchos trabajos juntos
en él
nosotros compartimos una visión que es
lo más importante lo que nos une
y también compartimos un sueño que era
culminar nuestra etapa académica
haciendo un vehículo
esto se potencia al en el tercer año de
la carrera estábamos cursando y vimos la
presentación final de otros chicos que
tienen un vehículo para el ámbito rural
esa fue nuestra motivación para decir
nosotros también podemos hacerlo bueno
cuando empezamos a cursar quinto año del
proyecto final nuestro sueño siempre era
querer hacer un auto teníamos esa pasión
teníamos ese sueño bueno vamos a
realizarlo
pero qué pasa la facultad nos dio un
brief es una especie de marco donde
meter un proyecto donde ese proyecto
tiene que tener tiene que estar hecho
para ese marco entonces el marco era la
agricultura familiar entonces es cómo
hacemos un vehículo para la agricultura
familiar es algo que no nos imaginábamos
y ahí empezamos a hacer salidas de campo
empezamos a visitar chacras empezamos a
visitar campos a conocer gente una
experiencia muy linda y nos dimos cuenta
que hay una necesidad latente muy
importante que es la necesidad de la
movilidad que en el ámbito rural esta
necesidad se ve en los vehículos que
tienen estas personas son vehículos
precarios son vehículos en mal estado
son vehículos obsoletos
donde estas personas tendrían que tener
exactamente los mismos vehículos con las
mismas calidades con las mismas
actualizaciones que los vehículos que
vemos en el ámbito urbano
empezamos a recorrer diferentes familias
agricultoras vimos que vehículos tenían
encontramos un caso donde se habían
creado su propio vehículo habían hecho
de ellos con tus propias manos un
vehículo para transportar hierba o sea
esa gente estaba creando la solución a
su propia necesidad y eso que nosotros
veíamos con como necesidad también era
una oportunidad era una oportunidad para
nosotros para que podamos ayudar a esto
para que podamos contribuir con algo
esta es una de las cuestiones más
importantes salir de la zona de confort
y nosotros nos dimos cuenta de esto
cuando salimos a confrontar con la
realidad a hablar con la gente y tenemos
una anécdota con un empresario del
ámbito de la venta de automotores en
donde fuimos conseguimos una entrevista
con él y le comentamos hasta él
el grado de avance que tenía nuestro
proyecto
la frase que nos dice es que es tenía un
vehículo expuesto en venta el cual él le
bajaba el precio y nos ganaba en el
negocio nosotros por qué porque nosotros
veníamos planteando un vehículo a
combustión entonces lo que nos dice es
que si el vehículo es eléctrico
desaparece la competencia no tiene como
competir ese fue uno de los grandes
puntos en donde nosotros decidimos desde
allí hacer un vehículo eléctrico con
todo lo que tiene que ver también con la
tendencia mundial
y otra anécdota que estos fueron puntos
muy importantes para nosotros ya que de
alguna manera son cuestiones que van
guiando el proyecto
fuimos a hablar con una productora de la
zona cercana a la ciudad ahora y sin
comentarle nada
estaban sabiendo de los desarrollos de
eléctrico y nos dijera que para ello
sería genial tener un vehículo eléctrico
y poder recargarlo con con paneles
solares instalados en su en su terreno
entonces
estas cosas nosotros las definimos como
prejuicios esos prejuicios son los que
nosotros todo todo el tiempo tenemos que
ir sacando nos porque esos prejuicios
son los que no nos dejan a nosotros ver
las realidades una de las cosas también
que estamos planteando es como hacemos
un vehículo estando en oberá están dos
misiones lejos de los grandes centros
automotrices que hay acá en argentina
la solución la respuesta estaba acá y
vamos a hacerlo donde estamos vamos a
hacerlo con los recursos que tenemos con
las herramientas que nos da la facultad
con el conocimiento y así fue cuando
como empezamos a gestar este vehículo
primero con dibujos después pasamos a
dibujos en escala real para corroborar
ciertos aspectos
las respuestas estaban en nuestro propio
entorno solamente las teníamos las las
teníamos que ver hay una cuestión que es
muy importante nosotros estamos haciendo
un vehículo la relación con el usuario
tiene que ser perfecta para eso tuvimos
que diseñar y crear ese ambiente lo más
cómodo posible
como nosotros en ese momento no teníamos
los recursos para fabricar el auto
entonces esto es algo muy importante y
hay que ser muy creativos con los
recursos que dispones en el momento y
como ven en la imagen generamos una
maqueta del interior del vehículo con
madera y tele o por cosas que las
podemos conseguir fácilmente y por eso
es difícil imaginarse que esto pueda
convertirse en un habitáculo de un
vehículo una anécdota muy emotiva que
tuvimos cuando estábamos haciendo esta
maqueta
como vídeo vivía en un departamento en
construcción o sea era un edificio
construcción dando bajo un departamento
constantemente había obreros transitando
por ahí y una noche estábamos con sandro
haciendo la maqueta y conectamos un
volante empezamos a jugar unos juegos de
autos para ver cómo sería manejar
nuestro propio vehículo en un juego y
uno de los obreros pasa más o menos
tenía nuestra edad
y nos ponemos a charlar con él nos
cuenta que es un ex convicto que se
estaba reinsertado en la sociedad él
vivía en el ámbito rural y ahora se
estaba pasando al ámbito urbano era la
posibilidad de trabajo que tenía era
momentánea y vivía en una vivienda
bastante deteriorada y bueno tímidamente
y se acerca a nosotros le decimos si
quería probar y empieza a jugar ese
juego y ahí nos dimos cuenta de algo que
no estábamos mirando de algo que no
estábamos observando que era este
vehículo tiene que hacer que esta
persona sea el protagonista cuando vimos
esas manos lastimadas agarrar el volante
de cuero en una computadora quizás nunca
haya probado eso ese chico pero para
nosotros significó un cambio sustancial
en todo el proyecto porque todos los
productos que tenemos nosotros están
hechos para los usuarios si no fuéramos
usuarios los productos no tienen que
existir y los productos tienen que dar
un significado
a la persona que lo está usando y eso
vimos como un punto clave para nuestro
para nuestro proyecto este proyecto
tenía que representar a esta persona
tenía
brindarles lo mejor tenía que dar toda
la calidad posible él como ven en la
imagen esto es un modelado 3d
de la propuesta que hicimos y esto es
algo que lleva mucho tiempo ya que ese
modelo hasta el último tornillo y es muy
importante porque nosotros de esta
manera lo que estamos modelando en tres
días pasa a producción directamente
entonces este es uno de los pasos más
importantes y que más tiempo lleva pero
antes de este paso está lo que le
veníamos comentando hay que corroborar
mucho con maquetas de estudio prototipos
y sacarse todas las dudas antes de
presentar este este modelo final para
producción bueno luego de ese modelado
3d empezamos a hacer el chasis del
vehículo un compañero nuestro que vivía
en la periferia de ahora vivía en una
chacra y sabía mucho sobre soldaduras y
nos dio una mano con el tema de comenzar
a hacer este chasis
y era algo como que no tiene esa
relación
hacemos un auto que va a pasar la
producción que va a ser reconocido pero
en la chacra o sea en cuál es la
relación después de mucho trabajo mucho
esfuerzo y dedicación
logramos presentar nuestro proyecto si
bien no lo presentamos como lo habíamos
pensado lo presentamos y de alguna
manera cumplimos nuestros sueños de
crear un vehículo
este chasis se representaba a esta
carrocería eso también era algo que
teníamos que dar ese valor demostrar que
este usuario iba a tener un vehículo
apto para él un vehículo que lo realce
un vehículo que tenga la misma calidad
que un vehículo que nosotros vemos en el
ámbito urbano entonces diseñamos dos
líneas de producto con una misma
plataforma con un mismo chasis y una
carrocería bastante similar en la que se
integran y se desintegran algunos
componentes se pueden variar las líneas
esta es la versión urbana y esta es la
versión rural también empezamos a
trabajar en todo lo que son los detalles
los detalles ante los que vemos como los
que nos vemos porque no son no solamente
diseñamos la parte exterior sino también
dónde va a estar alojado cada tornillo
como cada tornillo puede reducir un
costo para que esto tenga un costo mucho
menor y como el usuario se va a manejar
acá dentro cómo va a ser ergonómico como
va a ser seguro que es algo muy
importante una pregunta muy grande que
nos hicieron y nos hacíamos nosotros
mismos es como producimos esto estando
acá en misiones lejos de las grandes
automotrices y con esa falta de
estructura para llevar adelante un
proyecto así
y acá entra de nuevo esto de la
creatividad y el manejo de los recursos
y nos dimos cuenta que las respuestas
simples el modo de llevar adelante esto
es trabajando en grupo agrupando
empresas que con perfiles en este caso
metalmecánico manufacturas en fibra de
vidrio muchas empresas que podrían
fabricar una parte de este vehículo y
nosotros lo estaríamos ensamblando en un
solo punto entonces esto empieza a abrir
un camino más allá de la idea e
individualista y se transforma en algo
colectivo es para un desarrollo
colectivo y esto también genera mucho
valor genera empleo y realmente se puede
hacer una cosa que no imaginamos nunca
es cuando una semana después de que
presentamos el proyecto empezó a salir
en los medios y al principio salió en
diarios locales salió en revistas salió
a salió en programas de tele locales en
radios con sandro todas las mañanas
teníamos
algo que nunca habíamos esperado nunca
imaginábamos una experiencia totalmente
nueva después se pasó al ámbito nacional
en revistas en canales de tele gente de
distintas partes del mundo nos
preguntaba sobre el vehículo sobre cómo
lo hicimos y como lo pensamos cómo lo
diseñamos y era algo que no imaginábamos
y todo esto salió de acá de un edificio
en construcción y una chacra estando acá
misiones y nosotros no estamos acá para
mostrarles cómo se hace un auto no
estamos acá para mostrarle nada de eso
sino porque esto se puede aprender por
youtube o lo pueden golear estamos acá
para mostrarle que no hay límites para
nada para ninguna idea el único el único
límite que tenemos todos y que tienen
ustedes es que ustedes se pongan y con
esto bueno
entonces muchas gracias por compartir
este sueño con nosotros
[Aplausos]
[Música]